so as we get into our second part in our
conclusion of the Deadpool Killa
straited story and what we find here is
that we pick up with Ebenezer Scrooge in
A Christmas Carol that Ebenezer scroo is
at this particular point in time is
being shown what his future is of course
by the ghost of Christmas future
but like the story when he asked the
ghost of Christmas future what is what
his future holds if this is what his
future is going to be the story deviates
in the sense that Deadpool has killed
the ghost of Christmas future and what
he tells every Nizar Scrooge is that his
future is not going to be like this that
in actuality his casket is going to be
of the close variety meaning that he's
getting ready to kill everybody czar
Scrooge in a pretty gruesome way which
of course he does and so what we do from
here is we jump to the story of
Frankenstein now this idea of
Frankenstein is actually really really
cool and the reason why is because like
the story of Mary Shelley's Frankenstein
we see that of course dr. Frankenstein
brings the creature to life but what
happens like the story is that the
creature immediately rebelled but the
difference here is that when dr.
Frankenstein's trying to understand
what's going on when he's trying to
figure out what's wrong with the brain
of this creature we see Deadpool arrived
and Deadpool tells dr. Frankenstein that
he's killed Igor and that what he had
done is he had replaced the brain that
was supposed to be put in a Frankenstein
with a large portion of his own brain
and so what we see or what we learned
here is that dr. Frankenstein is killed
by his own monster but what we also see
is that as far as we can tell the
psychopathic Deadpool is now in the body
of Frankenstein and so for the rest of
the story we're going to refer to this
version of I Deadpool as Frankenstein
and the two of them go about the process
of again continuing to kill various
concepts and the end the idea verse
together and so what we do is we pick up
with Sherlock Holmes and his group and
what they're doing is they're continuing
to traverse the moat the the idea verse
we're continuing to go through here and
look at the fallout of Deadpool's
actions of course at this point they're
using the time machine from the story of
HG Wells and so what they find is that
alongside the island of doctor
Roah as well as Gulliver's Travels and
the story of Caesar that all these
various people are dead that of course
all the animals from dr. Moreau are dead
that the little people from Gulliver's
Travels have been killed by Deadpool and
Frankenstein and that all the members of
the Senate have been killed by a
Deadpool and Frankenstein and so what
they begin to realize here is that
Deadpool's not traveling alone that
someone is with Deadpool now and so they
have to hurry because now their efforts
are twofold main they can do more in a
shorter amount of time and so what we do
is we pick up with Deadpool and
Frankenstein and the story of the jungle
book now this one I like particularly
because this one actually sticks
relatively close to the story of the
jungle book it is to say how it was
written as opposed to the Disney version
we had seen of course with the original
version of the jungle book what we had
seen was that once Mowgli had been more
or less cast out of his village that he
had enlisted the help of various animals
and they went back and killed everybody
in the village but with this story we of
course already pick up with with Mowgli
who has Ramsar with Deadpool or
Frankenstein who have killed various
animals in the jungle and so Mowgli
ambiguity r2a Deadpool and Frankenstein
and ask them why they've done this and
Mowgli says it doesn't matter the only
thing that matters is that they deserve
to die for their actions
and so we see Bagheera and Mowgli both
attacked Deadpool and Frankenstein and
what Deadpool says here is that he's not
acting alone that Mowgli is mistaken if
he believes that his intention is
something other than to kill or dippel's
intention is to is something other than
to kill Mowgli and so what I did Poole
says is that he's enlisted the aid of
Shere Khan and so we of course see Shere
Khan the tiger arrived and what the
Frankenstein version of Deadpool tells
us here is that Shere Khan had agreed to
join the efforts even though Shere Khan
knew that he was going to be killed in
the end by Deadpool and Frankenstein and
so what happens is of course Shere Khan
along with Deadpool and Frankenstein are
able to kill everybody from the jungle
book including Baloo and as a result
Shere Khan is killed in the end and so
from this point we jump to the Caribbean
Sea and what we found with the Caribbean
Sea is that we're actually picking up
here with Captain Ahab and with Captain
Nemo and what they found here is the
wreckage of the Hispaniola the ship that
was written for the book
Island and what happens here is that as
they're going through this as we're
looking through various things they come
to a realization this realization being
that this ship the Hispaniola was around
long before the ship of captain ahab and
that again even Captain Nemo ship is far
more advanced and so basically things
are in the wrong time and so what seems
to be happening here is that the
multiverse the idea multiverse is
folding in on itself that all these
different realities a Deadpool is
jumping to are beginning to converge
into one and the time itself is
beginning to become I guess meshed
together or stream together to the point
where we see various AI characters from
different time frames existing at the
same point in time in the same universe
and so ultimately what we see is that
once they realize that the I'm sorry
that once they actually arrive at the
surface they come across a various
wreckage and what they do here is they
find a couple survivors now captain
Ahab's initial intention is to kill them
you simply views them as pirates and
says the desert is kind of treatment but
what I Captain Nemo says is they may be
able to shine the light on on what has
happened here on who it was that had
attacked this ship even more so than
that if it's the same individuals who
would attack Captain Ahab then then
they'll be able to trace these
individuals down find them and most
likely kill them but what happens as we
learn that these two captives are in
fact Deadpool and Frankenstein and so
again Deadpool and Frankenstein go about
the process of killing most everybody
the only person they don't kill yet is
Captain Nemo and the reason why is
because what we see them do is strap
Captain Nemo to a torpedo and then shoot
him out of his own ship at which point
he comes in a contact with a little
mermaid who was revealed to be I guess
the basis for before name of the
Submariner and and both of them died in
the process and so what we do is we we
switch over to issue number four to the
final story of this particular this
particular series and what we find is
that we're again picking up with
Sherlock Holmes and Sherlock Holmes is
going through and again giving us these
small vignette so these different
stories of characters a Deadpool has
killed that he's killed the entire story
or the entire basis behind the story of
Macbeth that he's killed the story
behind the Raven and the the Picture of
Dorian Gray now if you guys notice what
the Picture of Dorian Gray was really
interesting here is a Deadpool it shot
the picture
and there's a reason for that with the
portrait of Dorian Gray what we had seen
was that this was a story whereby a
young man named Dorian Gray would be
youthful forever as long as a picture of
himself was maintained because within
this picture was basically his soul and
the only way to kill him was to destroy
the picture and so this is the reason
why Deadpool had shot the portrait of
Dorian Gray because it was the only way
to kill him and so what we do is we
transition back to Deadpool and
Frankenstein at the strait of messina
and what happens here is Deadpool in
Frankenstein come across the Greek
mythological monsters of Silla and in
charge this I believe is how you
pronounce it another hundred sure but
while these two characters had existed
throughout Greek mythology ultimately
they're I guess the characters as far as
Deadpool knows about them was most
likely brought to him by the story of
the Odyssey by Homer and so what happens
here with these two Greek mythological
monsters is that sailors who were
travelling through the strait of messina
basically had to face one of two
obstacles either they could come across
charges who would consume their entire
ship Chartist was basically a giant
whirlpool and the strait of messina or
they could go across Scylla who would
most likely take six of their men then
of course during the story of the
Odyssey we had seen that the ship had
decided to go the route of coming across
some of Scylla and losing six of their
men and the process but nonetheless with
this particular story what we find is
that Deadpool and Frankenstein are using
the ship of Captain Nemo to basically
attack Scylla and what they do is they
they trap her they harpoon her and it's
revealed to us of course that still
represents Galactus and what they do is
they pull Scylla into the mouth of
charges and then Deadpool sets the ship
to explode and then teleports out which
results in both the Scylla in Chartists
being destroyed at the same time and
when they teleport out what we find here
is they arrive in Paris in 1627 and what
they do here is they basically encounter
the three musketeers and d'Artagnan
another of course with the idea of the
three musketeers Deadpool said that his
initial intention was to encounter them
at some point anyway and the reason why
was because he's angry at the fact that
the three musketeers candy bar doesn't
have any peanuts which i think is
actually a legitimate claim I love the
three musketeers candy bar I think it'd
be delicious if it had Pina
it's better than it is now but it
doesn't just like some solid block of
stuff but in any event what happens here
is a Deadpool of course alongside a
Frankenstein continue killing various
ideas and they kill the three musketeers
but what's really interesting here is
that one two three Musketeers are killed
by Deadpool Deadpool begins to realize
and not only the three musketeers
basically represent the team aspect or
even the very basis for the concept of
the Avengers and the x-men but that
various superheroes are beginning to die
in the process the concept of them are
beginning to go away and so what happens
here is that as they're getting ready to
take off as a getting ready to leave
they're confronted by Sherlock Holmes
and it's group and what Sherlock Holmes
says is that this is all going to come
to an end that everything is going to
stop now and so what happens is that a
basically a large fight breaks out
between the group of Sherlock Holmes and
Deadpool and Frankenstein now initially
Sherlock Holmes and Watson stay back and
what Sherlock Holmes tells Watson is
that eventually their time will come the
opportunity will unfold to where they
can take their action and they can do
what they can to kill either Deadpool or
Frankenstein or both and when this
opportunity unfolds we find that Watson
shoots Frankenstein in the head
effectively killing it and the
psychopathic voice of a Deadpool is
returned to his mind but what we
actually learn here is that this version
of Deadpool had never left this version
of Deadpool had been there the entire
time he had simply just been quiet and
so what we find out here is that as
Deadpool was trying to get away as he's
trying to leave any regroup that his
hand is cut off by Milan and again
Deadpool Milan gang engage in some sort
of a conflict here but ultimately
Deadpool is able to get to the time
machine that Sherlock Holmes and his
crew were using and use the time machine
to escape back into the end of the ocean
of the time stream I guess the best way
to describe it but Sherlock Holmes
travels with him and what Sherlock
Holmes says is that ultimately Deadpool
is not going to be successful here that
the idea verse will find a way to heal
but it'll find a way to return itself
but Deadpool says it doesn't matter that
the idea has already been planted here
and that if the idea verse does heal
itself that ultimately it will heal like
a bone that's not set right that it'll
be a twisted or it'll be somewhat
damaged but it'll never be the same
and what this seed has done that he's
planted is basically given us the idea
that superheroes can be killed that
superheroes can
I and so ultimately Deadpool slips back
into the timestream er back into the
ocean of time and we don't know exactly
where he goes from here but what we do
is we pick up with Sherlock Holmes again
as he's on this Time Machine trying to
keep the idea versus a lot of in the way
he's doing this it's like basically
remembering everything that he had seen
up to this point all the characters and
the stories that Deadpool had killed now
it seems as though he's successful and
that in some capacity the idea verse
will remain alive before we find out
what happens next this story comes to an
end with that being said I will catch
you guys later
please be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly